[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and i feel fine
[Music]
[Music]
are opening up for scientific
cooperation between countries
going up and apart
[Music]
well hello everybody and welcome from
the kennedy space center in florida i'd
like to
welcome everyone to the traditional
pre-launch
news conference uh following today's
launch readiness review
ahead of nasa and spacex's crew one
falcon 9 and crew dragon
flight to the international space
station um here to provide all the
details our
folks that were part of the review today
and also have been part of
a lot of the preparations that have led
up to this moment as a very exciting
day for everybody within nasa and spacex
and hopefully all of you that are tuning
in today
let me introduce the panel and then i'll
let each one of them
give you some words before we take
questions steve stitch he's the nasa
manager for the commercial crew program
here at kennedy
also joel montelbano the nasa manager of
the international space station program
at johnson space center in houston
norm knight he's the deputy manager
of flight operations directorate at
johnson
also joining us is benji reed who's the
senior director
human space flight programs at spacex
great glad to have him with us
also kurt costello who is the nasa iss
program
chief scientist at johnson space center
and last but not least is arlena moses
she's the launch weather officer for the
u.s air force
45th weather squadron so i know
everybody's looking forward to hearing
from harlena as well
with that i'll turn it over to steve and
let him take it from there
okay thank you kyle it's great to be
here uh
following the launch readiness review
today you know it's been a busy
a few days since we last talked we
talked to you after the
flight readiness review on tuesday uh
since that time uh we've put
uh the falcon 9 vehicle through a static
fire which is an important test for us
to check out the rocket to make sure
that the
nine engines on f9 and all the systems
on the rocket were functioning
as expected we reviewed all that data
over the last few days and the rocket
looks really good
it was important for us to also do some
inspections after that static fire
we've swapped out a couple of engines on
this vehicle and we did those
inspections and
and everything looks really good we also
did a uh a dry dress uh practice with
the crew the crew suited up got in their
space suits
went out to the launch pad and and got
in installed into the vehicle
it's the first time we put four people
in dragon so that was an important test
for us and that test went really really
well
overall in terms of looking at the
weather and also looking at a
recovery of the booster for this flight
we have adjusted the launch date we were
targeting a saturday launch
uh we've adjusted the launch date 24
hours later and today we're targeting a
sunday launch
at 7 27 pm eastern time that'll put
docking
on monday at about 11 pm eastern time
and we did that we looked carefully at
the weather and the onshore flow
looked really not so good for saturday
also we needed to get the the drone
recovery ship in place to recover the
booster
uh for nasa this booster and spacex this
booster is very important for us
we're gonna reuse the first stage uh
that we're flying on crew one
for the crew tube mission uh coming up
in the springtime
with the launch day that crew 2's got a
launch date of march 30th so it's
important to recover that booster and so
we need to get the drone ship in place
overall you know it's going to be an
exciting flight i will remind you that
crew one is going to be the longest
u.s space flight ever exceeding what we
had
on the the final skylab mission skylab
3.
it's the first mission to have uh four
exceeding what we had on the final
skylab mission skylab 3. it's the first
mission to have four the capsule
which we're excited about to enhance the
science on the space station and uh as
well as the first our first uh
faa flight uh fa license launch as well
as we're moving to this next step
so we're excited to go fly to synchronic
mission for the space station program uh
we'll continue to watch the weather and
the vehicles
and we're looking forward to a good
launch on on sunday and i'll turn it
over to joel montevano
thank you steve welcome again to today's
press brief
you know these past few days we've had a
number of reviews and operations as
steve's mentioned
and today as we concluded the launch
readiness review i can tell you that the
international space station partnership
is ready for this mission
you know as steve said looking at a
launch time of 7 27
eastern time 7 27 pm eastern time on
sunday giving us a docking
late monday evening approximately 11
pm eastern time shortly after docking
we'll do the
standard leak checks and then we'll have
a welcome ceremony on board that'll be
about two and a half hours after docking
this week we've been doing a lot of
discussion with
kate and sergey's on orbit today and
keeping them up to speed with the launch
preparations they're excited
and they're ready to have some new crew
members on board
this few this vehicle is also bringing
approximately 240 kilograms of
pressurized cargo
again to enhance what we're doing on
board the international space station
as steve said with these four crew
members adding to the three crew members
on board we'll have a total of seven
iss crew members for a sustained
increment uh this vehicle will stay up
there for a long duration increment
and return in april of next year so
we're looking forward to having the
extra capability on board
which will allow us to increase the
science we do
increase the exploration development we
do in order for the artemis program and
future programs
we're also this year celebrating 20
years of continuous human presence on
board the international space station
and during those 20 years we've set the
standard for international cooperation
and international operations
but we keep learning we learn every day
and you know
nasa with american industry and
has developed these commercial vehicles
that allow us to
bring more people to low earth orbit
bring more people to the international
space station
allow us to do more science in low earth
orbit and allow more commercial
opportunities
so with that a huge thanks to the
commercial crew program huge thanks to
spacex
for getting us to where we are today the
international space station partnership
is is glad to be here we're excited for
launch on sunday
we're looking forward to monday's
docking and a long duration increment
so with that i'll turn it over to norm
thank you
let's see thank you joel as was stated
the launch readiness review today
went very well we echo that and uh you
know stepping back
and kind of reflecting on demo two in
the development cycle now to the
operational cycle just
with you know kind of the journey
leading up to this in the lr
and it was really evident that there was
great improvement on
you know the closed out work the less
open work there was
and the overall readiness level uh from
the team
for this vehicle so it was uh it was
very encouraging
an absolute focus on crew safety and
vehicle safety
which uh both the nasa and spacex teams
have done a great job with
and we're very satisfied with that this
was on the heels of
dry dress yesterday that steve mentioned
that went very well that was the first
opportunity really to to
let the crew suit up and really try out
their vehicle
for the first time before launch day to
make sure that you know the
the fit was right and there were no last
minute type things that needed to be
uh tweaked up prior to launch and again
that went uh very well we're very
excited about that
had an opportunity to uh to meet with
the crew
this morning and talk with them a little
bit about their upcoming launch and i
tell you what they were
absolutely excited and you could just
feel the radiant
excitement coming off of them in fact
when i walked out
of that briefing i was i was excited
myself i mean you could just
feel the energy from the crew and uh and
we see that throughout the team
which is great because it means we're
real close
and we're ready to go which is uh very
important
um you know the the message that uh that
they wanted to convey is
is resilience and to echo once again
that you know the journey to get here
is one of resilience and it was a hard
journey with a lot of stuff going on and
covet affecting the teams but
it was that resilience and determination
by a lot of folks that have led up to
this point
we'll safely get them into orbit and
we'll safely
um get them docked performing six months
of science and returning back
uh to earth safely as well so again a
lot of folks that
that were involved with that and just an
appreciation
for that hard work that um that has got
us to this point so
it was very good so with that uh i will
turn it over to
benji and look forward to questions
later
great thank you very much norm um first
of all i just i it's sitting here and
i'm i'm excited
again to be here um to think that this
is
our third time that we've had the
opportunity to come and launch here from
kennedy space center
uh we did our in-flight abort test uh
back uh at the beginning of this year
we did our our demo two mission with bob
and doug and now we're coming up here on
crew one our first
operational mission to start providing
crude services
to the station to keep joel's program
running
um you know at six month intervals it's
just incredible and if you watch the
beginning here just before we started
this press briefing you saw the montage
they had of
all the different past crew missions and
to hear joel talk about 20 years in
space it's just
it's so cool and it's an honor to get to
be here i'm i'm certainly stoked
um on on behalf of um and all the spacex
employees
um our vendors our partners all of our
families
um you know i want to take this
opportunity to say thank you
um to nasa and to all of our partners to
let us be a part of this and to
help um carry this sacred really the
sacred um
honor and responsibility on our
shoulders
um this is the culmination of years of
work
and effort um from a lot of people and a
lot of time
and and we have built i think what i
would call as one of the safest
launch um and spacecraft launch vehicles
and spacecraft ever
and it's it's an honor to to be a part
of that
we uh we culminated our efforts in that
with our static fire on wednesday
steve mentioned that just a little bit
and in fact i think we have a video to
show for that
great that was a full seven second
duration static fire
um the teams looked at all the data
coming out of that static fire actually
they finished that up those reviews we
did joint reviews with the nasa teams
and our teams and looked great we
assessed everything that came from the
vehicle and we feel very good about it
as you know we did some work on the
engines
and other aspects of the vehicle as we
came into this getting ready for this
launch and that static fire is very key
to ensuring
that we're ready to go and like i said
that seven those seven seconds looked
awesome
the next thing i want to show you is a
picture that we have from dry dress
and dry dress is a dress rehearsal that
we do with the crew
and they do the whole thing where they
get suited up
at the building what they call the onc
building here on kennedy space center
they get suited up they come across in
their teslas and they go up the tower
and get all the way into dragon
and it's a very important process that
we do where we walk
walk through all of that with our teams
the ground teams working with the crew
the crew themselves and make sure
everything checks out
when i look at this picture again i get
very excited to think about this next
step
on this big journey that we have ahead
of us we've got four
astronauts who will be going up we have
one person who's never been to space
victor who's very excited
we have suici who's our first
international partner
who will be joining us which is really
really cool
all right let's talk a little bit about
what's going to happen on launch day
itself as i talked about dry dress was a
practice for
that so at about four hours before
launch day
um the crew will be in that onc building
they'll be in their area getting suited
up
our suit techs will be getting helping
them get ready we'll be doing various
leak checks and other fit checks as we
go through that
and then the the astronauts will come
out at about three hours before launch
get into the tesla's wave goodbye to
their families
and all their friends who are there and
then come across to the launch pad
they'll go up the launch tower come
across the crew arm
and at about two hours two and a half
hours before launch they'll be entering
the vehicle
they'll get inside the vehicle um
they'll get all strapped in
get all safe and about
approximately about double check my time
here
at about 45 minutes before launch is
when we'll do the final go pole
for um for loading the vehicle and
for arming the escape system we have the
launch escape system on dragon
that's ready to go just in case we need
to uh if something goes wrong with the
launch vehicle
dragon can escape the vehicle the uh the
crew to safety and splash down to the
ocean so that'll be armed
at that point at about 30 minutes before
launch is when we start loading the
launch vehicle
with propellants and uh and and we're
off
let's go next to our line drawing that
we have
this gives you a sense of what it looks
like when we're actually doing launch
i won't go through all the details we
come at some of the highlights here
about two minutes and 40 seconds we have
our first and second stage separation
after that happens the first stage will
land on the drone ship
which is heading out right now to be in
position to be ready for that
and then the second stage will continue
to carry dragon to orbit
about 8 minutes and 50 seconds into the
mission
the second engine will cut out shortly
after that dragon will
separate and they're off on their
phasing journey to station
if we go to the next line drawing we can
see that
we get a sense of what this looks like
so phasing is this process
where we're essentially catching up with
space station
the process is that you know space
station's zooming around the earth
very fast so is dragon and you're trying
to do this game where you're using
gravity
and the behavior of orbital mechanics as
well as minimizing the amount of fuel
that you have to use to catch up
and get the two vehicles to come
together so we go through this process
of phasing
and based on the orbital mechanics the
time the day of launch
in this case this particular phasing
time will take about 25 hours
about 25 hours we'll be close to where
we need to be
to uh to basically be in position to
come up to station
and then a few hours after that we'll
have docked to the space station
let's go ahead and we'll actually come
back and i'll talk a little bit about
what's going to happen once they dock
so the crew docks um on station
and of course obviously they're going to
come through and they'll be welcomed by
the other crew that's up there
and then start to get to work very
quickly two things that
particularly involve spacex that'll be
happening during their six months
up on station one is coming up in just a
few weeks we have our
cargo first cargo on our new
dragon 2 cargo vehicle but it'll be our
crs 21 mission
um we'll be heading up and that's full
of science um for
all of this crew for the crew one crew
to be working on
um so the first few weeks of after
they've docked they're going to be
getting ready for that they're going to
be wrapping up other work
and preparing and when crs-21 shows up
they'll be spending a lot of time
working on all the critical science
that's going on there
and then near the end of their time at
the end of the six months or so
we'll be sending up another dragon so
crew two dragon will go up
again with another four astronauts on
board and that dragon will go up
dock to station and again there'll be a
handoff
everyone will see each other hand off
the work and about a week later
our crew one crew will come home let's
take a look at what that looks like in a
line drawing
so you can see here we do another
departure
docking both the docking and the
undocking process is an automated
process it's fully autonomous
of course at any time during the docking
the astronauts are
are able to take control both astronauts
on the vehicle and iss
during docking and docking are watching
closely everything that's happening
i want to make sure everything's
happening correctly
as we move away from station we get into
position to actually start our phasing
to come home it's the same process
that i talked about we need to phase to
make sure that we're going to hit the
right spot
on the earth at the right time for
splash down
um after that happens the our recovery
crews will come out
and uh and they'll be uh they'll be
meeting the crew
we have a large recovery vessel plus a
couple of fast boats
the fast boats will go out and uh and
meet the crew
and uh and first thing they'll do is
they'll check the area they'll make sure
everything's safe for approach the
second fast boat will be recovering the
parachutes
and then the and then we'll go ahead
with our larger vehicle which will pull
um dragon out of the water
all right um one of the things i do want
to mention as we talk about
this recovery process we know that
everybody's very excited about
launch and very excited about recovery
and human space flight in general
we certainly do ask that everybody's
who's involved if you come out to watch
the launch or any of the different
operations that we're doing that please
uh you know wear your masks and
and follow social distancing guidelines
do the right things there to keep
everybody safe
and certainly during recovery we ask
that all the voters
pay good attention to what the navy and
the coast guard regulations are and what
their advisories will be
it's very important that we keep all of
our recovery crews and the crew
themselves the astronauts to keep them
safe
um i want to take one more moment here
to do a couple of important thanks
number one i want to thank all of the
spacexers
and their families um and in all of our
different teams and partners who've been
involved
in all of this effort to get us here
it's a it's a very big team and part of
certification
as we've gone through we talked about
the other day that nasa has now
certified all of our systems for human
space flight
that certification effort is really
important and it means a lot
and it represents the countless really
hours and hours of work
that were put in by all of these teams
it's dragon it's falcon
the ground teams the launch site teams
it's the factory it's all of our
hardware and software
operators everybody all of them have put
this put their time in and then
sacrificed and done the dedication
needed
the same is true for all of our nasa
partners and all the vendor partners and
all the time they put into it so a big
thank you there
and then finally a very important
special thank you
to the astronauts who will be flying
victor mike shannon and soichi
and to your families we thank you for
the trust that you've put into spacex
to get you to space to be there as a
lifeboat and to bring you home safely
thank you on behalf of all of us
now we'll hear from curt talk about the
science and the reason that these guys
are actually going up there take it away
kurt
thank you as joel mentioned earlier it
was
less than two weeks ago that we were
celebrating
20 years of continuous crude presence on
orbit
and we weren't celebrating an ending but
really just the end of the beginning
the launch coming up with additional
crew members to the iss
is the start of a new era for research
and discovery on board
the capabilities of the crew dragon
bringing
additional crew and samples back
to the site here at ksc
are an amazing capability we hope to
double the amount of crew time going
into
science and research we'll again have
easier access for those samples when
they come back
to earth and we'll have easier access to
our crew members
both pre and post flight to conduct some
of our human research
now we do have several investigations
going up on this flight
we've got about 28 kilograms of payloads
going up
some of those experiments will be
going up for soichi to include
education and public outreach
experiments for him
and then we have a student experiment
called genes in space
7 which will be looking at the humble
fruit fly
and how it adapts on orbit to
changes in circadian rhythm
circadian rhythm is our sensitivity to
the day night cycle here on earth
and if you can imagine imagine on orbit
when you have 16 day night cycles every
day
it can be a bit confusing to the body
well fruit flies are great little model
organisms they help us understand what's
going on in the human body because they
share about 75 of the genes
that cause disease in the human body so
we'll be looking at those
and then last but not least our
astronauts are members of our human
research team
and they'll be conducting a number of
experiments uh on themselves both before
during and after the mission one of
those is food
physiology which is looking at whether
nutritional changes
in the astronauts diet can be beneficial
for preventing
space flight impairments that we
typically see on orbit
so again for mike victor soichi
and especially my old alum shannon from
rice
godspeed and thank you so much for the
amount of
hard work and research you're going to
be putting in
thanks kurt and now the topic everybody
knows that likes to talk about is
weather so let's uh
turn it over to arlena and have her give
us the launch weather forecast
so you know as for us here in florida
we've been plagued by
tropical storm ada for most of the
upcoming weekend
a little uncertain at first if it was
going to clear out this weekend but
thankfully ada is well out to sea and
moving further with time and
with its passage it brought a bit of a
cool front through
here in florida though i know it doesn't
feel like it very much right now
if you're if you're here locally still
pretty warm and humid but
overall it's going to give us a pretty
good shot for
weather for our primary launch day so if
we can take a look here at the forecast
so uh we are looking right now at a
uh go uh weather excuse me i should say
a no-go weather probability of
40 percent uh with that uh kind of weak
front that came through
a couple days ago it's going to kind of
creep back north towards us and
gonna keep our winds light and variable
so that onshore wind component not going
to be as much of a concern for
our attempt to launch on sunday but we
are going to see some
few showers in the area with some
cumulus clouds and also with the concern
for uh flying uh the both the rocket and
the dragon
capsule through any precipitation any of
those showers
that may be out there during the launch
time
if we take a look at our backup window
going into wednesday so a couple days
later
we dry out quite a bit a nice
area of high pressure we get a true
florida cold front coming through so
temperatures
i can see you're going to be a bit cool
uh for at least us here in florida maybe
not for everybody
our rain chances drop quite a bit so we
only have concern for
a few clouds the downside is however
winds are going to be coming from the
northeast a little bit a little bit uh
stronger on that particular day but that
is a something that we'll be
monitoring uh with the weather so good
luck everybody and we'll be here doing
our part with the weather to make sure
we
launch successfully great thanks a lot
thanks everybody else um
we're ready for questions there's a lot
of people in the queue as you can
imagine
it's also been a long day we've got
about a half an hour so for question and
answer i'm gonna
call on you by name and affiliation and
if you can
try to uh limit your question to one
like one part question uh so that we can
try to get to as many
folks as we can on the line and uh first
up is marcia dunn
associated press oh yes hi i'm hoping
you can hear me
um for steve i'm i'm wondering what is
nasa's latest thinking about
elon being allowed into the launch
control of his latest lab test come up
negative and for benji how important is
it to have him on console in person for
this launch
thank you i think we got a little bit of
an audio problem
uh i think let's see i think marsha's
question is and
i don't know who this would be directed
to was uh
is there a concern relative to the
covid concern that elon musk raised
earlier via
text tweet i believe
let's see kyle i'll um i'll jump in and
start on that one
as was in the news today uh it was
reported that that
elon took several coveted tests and of
course that stirred up a bunch of
questions relative to
to uh you know health and potential
contamination but
what i can tell you is nasa uh and our
commercial partners have
a health stabilization plan
in place and really it's a protocol that
protects the flight crew
from any uh disease or any illness
because
you know if they're compromised that can
affect uh and jeopardize the mission so
we pay a lot of attention to that
and we've done that over many years this
is something that has been in place
back i think in the apollo time frame in
shuttle for all those missions and for
all the station
missions as well to make sure that we're
protecting the flight crew
and how we do this is that obviously the
crew
is when they come close to launch or put
into
a quarantine and they start that soft
quarantine about 21 days prior to flight
that that period is about from 21 days
to 14 days where that soft quarantine
they're really starting to isolate
reduce their their movement their
exposure to other folks
and then at 14 days to launch we call it
a hard quarantine
and that's where they're totally
isolated and
and really watch closely by the docks
so that's a protocol that's in place for
the for the crew
in addition to that that protocol also
is for
all folks that that have contact with
the crew
so what we do is we train uh our
personnel both our personnel
and spacex personnel in this case uh
what these protocols are we train them
we make sure that um that we understand
uh hygiene uh social distancing
uh mass requirements when around the
crew
you have to have certain protocols met
before you can get close to the crew
whether you're training the crew or
getting them prepped for launch
and those people also depending on the
the level
of contact they have with the crew are
covered tested to make sure that
that they are safe and again that access
is very restricted so you can kind of
think of it as concentric circles on
the crews in the center and protecting
as it goes out and as those circles go
out
again those protocols change relative to
the contact that people have with the
crew
now if any of those personnel in that
ring
or any of those rings uh comes up uh
with any covet type symptoms
uh they're tested and we do contact
tracing to make sure
that we knew who they were around and
what what impact that could possibly
have
to the team so again we have a health
stabilization place
or a plan in place and it has worked
effectively for many years just like
it's working
today in this covent environment vinci
would you like to add any specific words
for the spacex team
sure absolutely you know um first of all
it's important to remember that we have
thousands of people working at spacex
and it takes all of those people to to
work together to build the systems that
we do and to launch rockets and
and launch the dragon spacecraft so um
it's important that we understand that
you know
that any one of our our our team members
um if they do have code or or get a test
or whatever then we
we we work through that um and we have
all of the protections in place that we
do
to maintain to make sure that
everybody's safe certainly in the case
of our launches
in the case of the crew everybody's safe
we do the contact tracing
that needs to be done and i can assure
everyone that that we're looking good
for
the crew one launch and all of the
critical personnel involved
thanks i think one more thing for the
hsp
you know it's the restricted access and
everything and no one's above this
access it doesn't matter if if you're
elon musk or jim bridenstine
if you have not met those protocols or
if any of those protocols have been
compromised
then we're not going to let you near the
crew and again it's to protect the
overall mission
that we're trying to accomplish and
everybody recognizes that it's it's
no surprise thanks to you both um i
think we have the audio problem fixed
we'll uh
go to gina cinceri abc news
okay now let's go to the next one i
think let's try bill harwood with cbs
news
i'm here kyle can you hear me yep
great um i'm not sure who this is for
but uh just a really quick question and
if you've already covered this i
apologize in advance i had some phone
problems
was part of the issue today the expected
weather in the recovery zone in other
words
was the forecast to be out of limits or
was the forecast favorable and the drone
ship couldn't get there in time
or was it both thanks
it's uh fundamentally this is uh it was
an issue of getting the drone ship there
in time
um the weather was such because of this
tropical storm that we couldn't get the
drone ship to leave in time um and get
there and the sea states are such that
we just can't get the speed up to get
there
that we were hoping to to hit the
saturday launch we were able to leave
uh port yesterday around midday and
and now we're going to be getting there
in time for plenty of time for a sunday
launch
okay next is paul brinkman united press
international
go ahead paul hi yes thanks for taking
my call can you hear me
yes sir okay um yeah my question is
about the uh just about the change
um if one of you could walk us through a
little bit of uh i guess
norm or benji about what happens when
you delay a launch
uh by a day like this and a crude launch
um you know does anything have to be
done to the capsule
or uh i'm assuming no more fuel has to
be added for a longer flight
but um do does the crew have to repack
their cargo or in a different way or
anything like that since they're going
to be up there
three times longer than they are they're
going to be in flight longer
than they thought they would thanks
see benji why don't you start out with
the vehicle the vehicle sure absolutely
so
in terms of the vehicle uh really
there's nothing different that we do
right we we were we checked out ready as
we went through all those tests that i
talked about um in the lead up really
many months up to launch and now we do
these tests this week to make sure we're
ready we go through these
flight readiness reviews like we wrapped
up earlier this week the launch rates
review
all of these are actually go for launch
tomorrow the only thing that that's not
go for launch is having that joint ship
and position and overall weather
um and so that's that's really key
there's nothing more that we do other
than continue to check and double check
and triple check
right this is the this is what we're all
doing all of our engineers all of us
will be
looking at data ensuring that everything
is ready to go to take the crew safely
and also it's going to be a good
opportunity for people to catch up on
some rest
and then from a crew standpoint you know
whether they're getting to space station
in eight hours or 27 hours
flight day one rendezvous or flight day
two rendezvous from a crew perspective
on what they take it's pretty much the
same now their timeline will change
because for a saturday launch they
literally would have stayed up and
pressed through
uh docking for the case of sunday it's a
flight date two launch
and uh so what that entails is the crew
will actually go to sleep in dragon
and wake up and then jump into the
rendezvous
profile and uh you know to prepare them
to dock
for station also for slips like this
depending on
you know the timing of that there could
be cargo that has to come off or science
that has to be refreshed and
maybe kirk can address that but i don't
believe that's the case for for sunday
okay next up is tarek malik space.com
go ahead tarek hello uh
thank you so much uh and uh my question
i think also is for norm about the
the extended uh trip for the
the crew one uh uh astronauts there
uh you know on on the last flight with
demo two uh with
kind of this lengthy uh trip we saw
kind of a lot of glimpses into what life
on
uh the crew dragon was like and i'm
curious with this
added time what we can expect to see
from the astronauts on this one will we
get
kind of like a tour a taste of what that
that trip is going to be like on monday
prior to their arrival
if you can kind of walk us through what
to expect and what the viewers might
expect
thanks okay well i'll start it out big
picture and then turn it over to benji
and and he can provide some
some details relative as well but you
know again
launch is a big deal the crew gets up
they prep they get on the vehicle they
go launch
um and then obviously once they get into
orbit they're going to do a series of
orbital
burns to get them set up like benji said
for that phasing
to get to station uh the crew has a
timeline
um and we can get you information on if
there's kyle i don't know if there's any
press briefings in that time but the
crews can constant
contact with the ground and so i'm sure
you know
you will be hearing uh from them
relative to that they go to sleep
they'll have a standard sleep period
they wake up
after sleeping and dragging and start
getting prepped again eat breakfast
get situated start prepping for the day
because it's a very important day
that you start doing those critical
burns
getting ready for the rendezvous profile
to get set up
for docking and you know there's uh
there's time in that day
obviously for if anything goes wrong and
then once they're on station they
utilize that time
as was stated earlier to uh to really
learn uh about station
uh learn what to do in case of an
emergency and obviously learn how to use
a lot of the facilities on station that
are gonna be very important once they're
docked
so benji i don't know if you had
anything to add
um sure you know it gives them more
opportunity to try out dragon
and to it and to be as a crew of four
members and dragon which i think will be
probably i assume exciting for them but
also it'll be great for us to to learn
what that is because it's important
um to understand that our that's a fully
capable dragon with all four seats
occupied
so we want to understand what that's
like and you know they'll be getting out
of their suits and floating around just
like we saw bob and doug do
um i'm pretty sure there are a couple of
broadcast events that they'll be able to
do with this time period
um and uh you know checking things out
seeing the earth go by
um i know i'd love to be there too so
it's great
[Laughter]
uh okay let's see let's go to i think
joey roulette is next with reuters go
ahead joey
hey thank you a question for joel i was
wondering if you could give us an
update on what the talks with russia are
to from mutual flights to the iss
are you envisioning some kind of
bilateral bilateral agreement
um and and when do you think the soonest
we can we can know
uh when you know we'll be able to fly
russians on a u.s crew vehicle will be
thanks so we're looking to fly on each
other's vehicles
probably later in 2021 where we'll have
a cosmonaut flying on our u.s commercial
vehicles
and an astronaut on the soyuz vehicles
we're working the what we have to do the
first
kind of the first step is what we call
an implementing arrangement
that we work at the government level and
so we're working with our state
department
to draft that we submitted the draft
they'll be reviewing it giving us
comments
once that's complete we'll turn it over
to roscosmos
and then they'll work it within their
government they'll get it back to us
we'll have probably
another iteration or so but all that
with the goal
of flying in late 2021 on each other's
vehicles
okay the next question is from uh morgan
is
morgan from business insider go ahead
hi um steve mentioned the other day that
crew 1 is launching on an
f9 with upgraded turbine wheels and copv
he um
said that these upgrades have been
flowing on falcon 9's for years but that
this would be their first crew so i'm
just wondering
why did demo 2 launch with older
versions of those turbine wheels
and copd and also benji said that the
crew dragon vehicle is now more robust
to tolerate a wider range of weather
conditions on splashdown so i'm just
wondering
what changes people burn to specifically
and how they make the vehicle more
robust
thanks so much
yeah i'll i'll take that benji thanks uh
let's see
so we do have a few upgrades uh flying
on crew one and
one of the things we've been working uh
with spacex on is how do we continue to
evolve this vehicle how do we continue
to make it better
so uh the composite overwrap pressure
vessels on falcon 9
many of them have an upgraded liner it
makes that liner a little bit more
robust
spacex to improve that liner and and
will allow it to be used a little longer
the turbine wheels on this vehicle have
been upgraded
it's a pretty complicated process to
design a turbine wheel
wheels are prone to actually when you
get to a certain
setting of the throttle on the engine
you can have certain conditions set up
that it resonances and so these wheels
are a little bit more robust
to the kind of throttle profile that the
merlin engines fly
so we're happy to have that as a safety
upgrade and then
also for landing we've made some
improvements to the structure
so that we can handle a little bit more
wind uh at the landing zone
which gives us some more a few more
opportunities to land so
those are three upgrades on this vehicle
and
you'll continue to see upgrades with
crew 2 and future vehicles to improve
safety
okay let's see i guess uh jackie wattles
cnn
are you out there jackie hey i sure am
uh thanks so much for doing this uh
another covered question i
i was curious if i could get some
insight um into how the contract
contact tracing played out who was in
charge of it was it spacex or nasa or a
joint team
um and then i don't know if finji or
anyone else can speak to
as well like if you know there was
something to a rise in hawthorne at
mission control
you know how that might play out
logistically
sure sure um you know i think that the
way that we
work from a medical viewpoint with us in
nasa is that we have flight surgeons we
actually have spacex company flight
surgeons
as well as nasa has flight surgeons and
of course they have the entire
uh health and human medical um
directorate that that
we all work very closely together and
our flight surgeons talk to the nasa
flight surgeons in fact ours have come
from nasa
um and and so they've worked out not
only following the
the health stabilization protocols that
we talked about that norm talked about
but
just also overall good practices
processes procedures making sure we're
following cdc guidelines local
guidelines
including with the contact tracing um
they've we've worked that you know these
are things that
while we'll do things on our side like
do the contact tracing ourselves for
how we're managing all of our staff we
provide that data and we
do that with nasa and we make sure
everybody's uh you know feeling really
good about where we're at
in terms of critical staff for example
like you asked at uh operations in
hawthorne
or here at the cape for example in our
in our launch control and firing rooms
we also have plans in place right we
have backup operators
our operators have also been at a
heightened level
of care they actually go into a type of
quarantine themselves
very limited public involvement access
different things that we do we do a lot
of temperature checks and screenings we
do a lot of tests
to ensure that all of our operators will
also be ready
for the launch and for the long-term
mission as well it's important to note
that all that great science
that's going to be going on on station
requires six months of work
um and that means the dragon will be up
for six months so we'll be monitoring
dragon systems
um and and of course just like how nasa
is continuing to fly iss
we need to make sure all of these
critical personnel are healthy for the
long
haul i'll just follow on on the contact
tracing
if if there's any thought or any concern
of compromise
to the flight crew the nasa team will be
doing that contact tracing and following
back and of course
working with our our partner spacex to
to do that trace or wherever or whatever
contractor
or nasa facility that might have come
from and we will trace that back and
find out the impact
for the specific teams uh if they've not
had contact with the crew we don't
believe they've had contact with the
crew that's left to
you know nasa or whatever specific
contractor
um to do those contact tracings and as
benji said
it's there's overarching guidelines it's
all
under the auspice of the health
stabilization program
and again all the guidelines that are
set forth so it's very rigid
and it's very thorough okay next up
is kenneth chang new york times go ahead
ken
okay let's see who's next in the queue
just waiting for that update um
i guess ken dropped off
susie from business insider is that
right
yep thank you um
so my question is uh what are the launch
dates be on sunday and where the most
ideal launch dates be on sunday if you
have to delay again
and what do they see in weather
conditions at the splashdown sites look
like for sunday in terms of what's
required for emergency recovery
yeah i can take that question so uh
we have a series of launch dates coming
up uh obviously
sunday is our prime date and then we
would stand down
on monday uh monday there's a
spacewalk going on in the iss and so
that's not a good day to go
up in rendezvous and dock to the space
station
tuesday also is not a good day it's a
little longer rendezvous profile
and so we really don't want to take that
runway profile
so the next opportunity would be
wednesday
thursday friday in the middle of next
week
uh right now for sunday the weather
looks looks pretty good down in this
along the coast uh what we do is we
protect
for an escape all the way from the
launch pad all the way up into orbit and
so
we have weather constraints and so right
now those look pretty good for uh
for monday we haven't really looked that
far out to wednesday in the middle of
the week but right now the conditions
look good
not only for the uh launch abort weather
but also for recovery weather
for the drone ship which is important to
us as well so
we're pretty well set up for sunday and
as arlene said we just have to watch
a little bit the local weather here as
this front comes through do we get
some precip or some thunderstorms along
that front line so
okay thanks steve thanks everybody
that's all the questions that we had
um let's see that leads us to sunday
what everybody's talking about the
preparations for launch
are ongoing obviously with our nasa tv
coverage is going to continue and start
at 3 15
p.m eastern time on sunday we have a
comprehensive
broadcast plan for you guys so make sure
that you tune in for that of course the
launch is
mentioned is targeted for 7 27 pm
uh eastern time from launch complex 39a
the starting point for crew one's
adventure if you will to the
international space station
with that launch uh sunday evening crew
dragon resilience
and its four astronauts are scheduled to
dock at about 11 p.m
as you heard on monday as well
so uh thanks to you guys thanks to
everybody tuning in today
and one reminder just keep practicing
social distancing
and go crew one thanks again everybody
[Music]
you